(lighthearted music)
(sniffing)
- [Voiceover] Oh, god. What is that smell?
Wait, was that me?
Nah, I know my own brand.
Okay Zack, just act cool. Act cool.
You didn't do this, alright?
Just act like you're
working at your computer.
No one will think you dropped
this massive fart bomb.
Is it getting worse? Yup, it's worse.
It is really bad right now. Oh, my gosh.
You know what? Maybe
I'll just hold my breath.
One, Mississippi. Two,
Mississippi. Three, Mississippi.
Four (exhales). Not gonna work.
Which one of you did it?
Was it you, Justin? No,
Justin would own up to it.
What about you, Doctanian?
Or you, Claudia? Or Janine?
Oh, I bet it's you, Janine.
Look at your smug look.
While you're pretending to work
while the rest of us
suffocate in your poop dust.
(sniffing)
Ugh, thank god it passed.
(farting)
- Okay, who did it? It smells so bad.
You need to just go home
or change your pants.
Who? Come on.
- I know right? Just go home, Janine.
- Oh, is it Janine?
- Yeah. It has to be. 'Cause it wasn't me.
- Ya smell like a dumpster.
Alright? You need to get that checked.
Freakin' Janine.
- Did you guys say something?